okay we recently told you about a pro de
Santa Super PAC which released its first
anti-trump bed we now have Donald Trump
posting a hardcore Ron DeSantis attack
ad to truth social essential
um and what's interesting is that some
of the claims that it makes it's a very
aggressive very vicious attack out but
the claims it makes aren't exactly
bulletproof which might not come as a
shock to you let's take a listen to a
struggling big time in his primary race
for governor of Florida polls revealed
DeSantis was failing so bad he was
losing by a staggering 17 points then
DeSantis was saved by the endorsement of
President Trump Trump's support was so
powerful just two days after the
endorsement DeSantis took a commanding
lead and it propelled him to being
elected I'd like to thank our president
for standing by me when it wasn't
necessarily the smart thing to do you're
unfortunately instead of being grateful
DeSantis is now attacking the very man
who saved his career I dare time
DeSantis remembers how he got to where
he is make America great again big
league so good build the wall then Mr
Trump said you're fired I love that part
truth is there's only one person who can
make America great a again yeah so you
know this entire thing about how uh the
day at two days after the endorsement
DeSantis just shot up I encourage you to
go back and look at the polls Real Clear
Politics has like a uh a polling
historical polling trend line on that
race and it is true that eventually
DeSantis surged as the election got
close but it wasn't over the summer when
Trump claims that his endorsement in 48
hours turned the race around it was
months later now you can debate whether
it was thanks to Trump's endorsement
months earlier I'm not even trying to
have that debate with you the story
that's being told DeSantis was dead
and then I endorsed them and 48 hours
later he was absolutely crushing in the
polls it's just not what the polling
data shows when you look at it
retrospectively so I do think that you
know Trump's in a position where there's
the real reason he's angry with DeSantis
and then there's what stuff can he use
to criticize the santis there's a little
bit of a dissonance between the two the
real reason Trump's furious at DeSantis
is that DeSantis not ruling out running
is seen by Trump as totally disloyal the
problem is Trump's going after DeSantis
for like for example saying Trump's uh
sorry this Trump says desantis's covet
numbers are terrible they're mediocre
they're not terrible they're not good
Florida is very mediocre in most metrics
so when Trump used to praise DeSantis on
kovid now he attacks him on covid the
truth is it was was both sort of like
it's not great in Florida but they
benefit from the warm weather and people
being outdoors and so like the numbers
aren't as bad as they could be he wants
to cut and gut Social Security
and he voted for a study group proposal
that was non-binding which would have
raised the retirement age is that a sort
of cut yes did he really vote for the
cut well everybody knew it wasn't going
anywhere it was just a study group
proposal is that a really strong
critique particularly when Trump has
also said I would look at entitlements
not really and so Trump if this really
gets going is going to have to find
something a little more solid I guess I
would say with which he can go after Ron
DeSantis